[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم
حسن جمله
كاس العالم قطر 2022 في يومها السادس عشر
هذه الصور من محيط استاد 974 في الدوحه
استعدادا للشوط الثاني من مباراه البرازيل
وكوريا الجنوبيه
ومن مدينه ريو دي جانيرو ثانيه كبرى مدن
البرازيل متابع هذه الصور من مشجعين منتخب
السنبا وهو متقدم في الدوحه باربعه اهداف
دون مقابل على نظيره الكوري الجنوب
ومن الخرطوم تصلنا هذه الصور بعد ساعات من
اعلان اتفاق اطار بين مجلس السياده في
السودان وعدد من القوه المدنيه يؤسس
لمرحله الانتقاليه مدتها 24 شهرا
وتعارضه هو سياسيه
وننهي هذه الجوله ميكيات في يوم اخر من
يوميات حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا وقصفها
المتزايد لمحطات توليد الطاقه في مناطق
مختلفه من البلاد
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد اكثر من عام من الاحتجاجات في السودان
مجلس السياده وقوه مدنيه واقعان اتفاقا
سياسيا لتاطير مرحله انتقاليه جديده
البرهان يتعهد في لقاء مع الجزيره بمعالجه
اخطاء النظام السابق بشان المؤسسه
العسكريه
واحمده يصف قرار الاستيلاء على السلطه يوم
الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر بالخطا السياسي
الازمه السياسيه تتصاعد في تونس حركه
النهضه تقول ان انتخابات 17 من ديسمبر
النيابيه ستعمق الانقسام وتحذرون من
تداعيات مقاطعتها
ترقب لخيارات قيس سعيد بعد انتقادات اتحاد
الشغل وجبهه الخلاص لمساره السياسيه
وارتفاع التضخم الى مستوى قياسي يثير
المخاوس
[تصفيق]
في احدث موجه من القص روسيا تستهدف
اوكرانيا بوابل من الصواريخ ضربات في شمال
والجنوب تتسبب في انقطاع التيار الكهربائي
على نطاق واسع
الرئاسه الاوكرانيه تقول ان الدفاعات
الجويه اسقطت معظم الصواريخ الروسيه
والجيش الروسي يقول ان طائرتين مسيرتين
اوكرانيتين هاجمتا قاعدتين جويتين روسيتين
مع دخول سقف لسعر النفط الروسي حددت هدوء
لون غربيه حيز التنفيذ الكريم يقول ان
الاجراءا لن يؤثر على الحرب في اوكرانيا
ويحذر من زعزعه استقرار سوق الطاقه
العالميه والبيت الابيض يستبعد حدوث
تداعيات بعيده المدى على الاسعار العالميه
في لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على منصاتنا
الرقميه ناقشنا توقيع عددا من القوه
المدنيه في السودان اتفاق اطار سياسيا مع
مجلس السياده يؤسسوا لمرحله الانتقاليه
مدتها 24 شهرا تبدا من تاريخ تعيين رئيس
جديد للوزراء وتنتهي باجراء انتخابات
شامله وقبل الاتفاق برفض عدد من القوى
السياسيه في البلاد لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان
هذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم السؤال
الثاني برايكم ما هي فرص نجاح اتفاق
الاطار في السودان على ضوء معارضه بعض
القوى
% قالوا ان فرص نجاح الاتفاق كبيره بينما
قال اسناني وثلاثون في المئه انها محدوده
وراى
45% ان فرص النجاح معدومه
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصات
الرقميه يمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر مسح
رمز كيو ار
الظاهر على الشاشه
لقضايا مستجد ومتفاعله عربيا ودوليا
وبعد الحصاد مباشره وتحديدا في الساعه
الثانيه عشر وخمس دقائق بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه تتابعون الجوله الرياضيه اليوميه
يوميات المونديال والتي ترصد بالخبر
والتحليل مباريات كاس العالم قطر 2022
[موسيقى]
رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان عبد الفتاح
البرهان مع اكثر من 50 حزبا سياسيا ومنظمه
من منظمات المجتمع المدنيه
والحريه والتغيير مجموعه مجلس المركزي على
اتفاق ايطابي يمهدوا لاقامه سلطه مدنيه
كامله لاداره الفتره الانتقاليه وصولا الى
الانتخابات وعلنا قوه سياسيه ولجان
المقاومه رفضها للاتفاق ووصفته بالهزيل
ودعت لمناضته بسبل السلميه
بهذا التوقيع يدخل السودان مرحله انتقاليه
جديده وينهي مرحله الفراغ الدستوري
والتنفيذي القائد العام للجيش السوداني
عبد الفتاح البرهان ووسط حضور دولي اكد
السعي الى تحويل الجيش لمؤسسه دستوريه
تخضع للقانون
الجيش الى مؤسسه دستوريه
تخضع للدستور والغنون والقيام والمؤسسات
الديمقراطيه المنتخب
[تصفيق]
الجهد الدولي ممثلا في الاليه الرباعيه
والامم المتحده والاتحاد الافريقي ومنظمه
الايجاد كان حاضر في الاتفاق الايطالي
رسائل ممثل الامم المتحده في السودان كانت
واضحه ومباشره للقوه السياسيه السودانيه
ان تبدا المرحله الثانيه لهذه العمليه
السياسيه الى الفورش
لمعالجه القضايا الالقه
الشامل
وستكون السلطه الانتقاليه الجديده التي
تحتوي على عده مؤسسات مدنيه بالكامل وسيجر
خلالها ادماج قوات الدعم السريع في القوات
المسلحه كما جرم الاتفاق الانقلابات
العسكريه
الاتفاق الايطالي
المتعلقه بالعداله والاصلاح الامني
والعسكري ومراجعه اتفاق سلام جوبا وهي
قضايا يرى المواقعون على الاتفاق انها
تحتاج لمزيد من التشاور باوسع مشاركه
ليتاسس عليها مشروع الدستور الانتقالي عقب
التوقيعي على الاتفاق النهائي
في المقابل عرض الاتفاق قوه سياسيه عديده
بدءا من الحزب الشيوعي والحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه فضلا عن مبادره نداءها
للسودان وتنسيقيات رجال المقاومه هذه
الاتفاقيه وهذا التوقيت الذي ياتي اليوم
رغم انفاس والمفروض على السودان وليس
هنالك ليس وطنيين يوقع على هذا الاتفاق بل
مفروطه التي السودان
وفي موازات هذه المواقف شدد التنسيقيه
رجال المقاومه من حراكها الرافدين لوجود
العسكريين في المشهد السياسي مناطق متعدده
في الخرطوم شهد التظاهرات الشعبيه رفعت
شعارات ممدده بالتوقيع على الاتفاق
الايطالي نزار البداوي الجزيره الخرطوم
قال نائب رئيس مجلس السياده في السودان
محمد حمدان احميدتي انما جرى يوم الخميس
والعشرين من اكتوبر كان خطا سياسيا وفتح
الباب للمزيد من الانقسامات واكد اهميه
الاتفاق الايطري للانتقال بالسودان نحو
الديمقراطيه
كانت هناك اختلافات
سياسيه خاطئه
ادت الى ما حدث في 25 اكتوبر
وهو ايضا خطا سياسي فتح الباب لعوده القوه
المضاده للثوره
وقد انتبهنا لذلك منذ اليوم الاول
وعملنا على معالجته بالتواصل مع قوه
الثوره حتى وصلنا لهذا اليوم
انما وقال عليه اليوم الاتفاق هو خطوه
اوليه واساسيه لمعايده الاخطاء السياسيه
ومعالجه الاختلالات
اختلالات الدوله وبناء دوله العداله
قال رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان في مقابله مع الجزيره ان
الاتفاق الايطاليه مفتوح للجميع وان كل من
يريد الانضمام اليه يستطيع ذلك كما اكد
البرهان ان هذا الاتفاق ليس نهائيا
هذه القاعده مفتوحه الان للجميع وكل من
يريد ان يلحق بهذا الامر
النقاط مطروحه للنقاش يحضر ويشتري في
الوراثه
ويعدل ما مكتوبه الان هذا الامر الذي
اتفقنا عليه الان ليس نهائيا هو امر يطرح
وسيقول فيه سودانيون رايهم ومن ثم يتحول
الى دستور او الى همم سائق تحكم الفتره
الانتقاليه
وانافع عبد الفتاح البرهان رئيس مجلس
السياده السوداني في مقابله مع الجزيره
وجود املاءات من الخارج واكد انه لا يمكن
سماحه لاحد بان يفرض مثل هذه الاملاءات
من الخارج نحن وطنيين نحن سودانيين نحن
نقدر المسؤوليه الوطنيه
نقدر حتى قيمه السياده وقتلنا عمرنا كله
من اجلس في هذا الوطنيه لا يمكن ان نقبل
باي املاءات ولا يمكن نسمح لاحد بان يفرض
علينا املاءات من الخارج هذا الامر مردود
على كل من يقول هذا الامر
لحظه الخارجيه الامريكيه بتوقيع الاتفاق
الايطالي في السودان واعتبرته خطوه نحوه
تشكيل حكومه انتقاليه بقياده مدنيه واكد
بيان للوزاره ان الولايات المتحده
وشركائها يعتبرون جهود تشكيل حكومه بقياده
مدنيه في السودان عاملا اساسيا لاستئناف
المساعدات الدوليه
معنا من الخرطوم سلمان نور عضو قوه الحريه
والتغيير مجموعه المجلس المركزي ومن
الخرطوم ايضا نور الدائم طه القيادي في
قوى الحريه والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه
نبدا معك سيده سلمى ما الذي يجعل هذا
الاتفاق مختلفا عن الاتفاقات السابقه التي
لم تنفذ
اه طيب السلام عليكم مرحبا بالمشاهدي قناه
الجزيره ومرحبا بك ومرحبا بضيفك الكريم
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي وقع اليوم ما يجعله
متميز عن الاتفاقات التي سبقته من اتفاق
21 نوفمبر والاتفاق الوثيقه الدستوريه
2019 هو انه جاء
بدوله مدنيه وسلطه مدنيه كامله بدون شراكه
مع المكونه العسكري كما هو الحال في
الوثيقه الدستوريه وكما هو الحال في اتفاق
الواحد والعشرين من نوفمبر ايضا هذا
الاتفاق همم ذهب الى ذهب بالمكونه العسكري
او الجانب العسكري بالكامل الى السكنات
ولم
ااه
ولن يكونوا مجددا في السلطه او في الحياه
السياسيه هذا اولا ثانيا هذا الاتفاق همم
تحفه وتدعمه مجموعه راسي عامل الاحزاب
السياسيه
والتجمعات المهنيه ومنظمات المجتمع المدني
هذا ايضا همم ما يميز هذا الاتفاق من
اتفاق 21 نوفمبر ان اتفاق 21 نوفمبر كان
اتفاقا ثنائيا بين همم الفريق البرهان واا
دكتور عبد الله حمدو ولكن هذا الاتفاق فيه
قاعده واسعه جدا تدعمه من الاحزاب
السياسيه والتجمعات المهنيه كذلك منظمات
المجتمع المدني ايضا هذا الاتفاق همم
حل كميه من المشاكل والقضايا العالقه في
الفتره الانتقاليه وقضاء الفتره
الانتقاليه منها الاصلاح الاقتصادي
والاصلاح الامن والعسكري بالاضافه الى همم
ازاله التمكين والانتخابات والدستور
الدائم الى اخر القضايا التي يناقشها هذا
الاتفاق ايضا هذا الاتفاق وضع اطار واضح
لتشكيل الحكومه الانتقاليه ووضع اي مكون
من المكونات في الحكومه الانتقاليه والدور
والدور واضح للمكونات المدنيه في الحكومه
الانتقاليه التي ستشكل بناءا على الاتفاق
النهائي لهذا الاتفاق اذن هذه هذه هذه
المميزات هذه المميزات لعله ابرز هذه
المميزات ما ذكرتيه عن ان الاتفاق همم ينص
على سلطه مدنيه بدون المكون العسكري الذي
همم يفترض ان يكون مقره في السوقنات هنا
اسال السيد همم نور الدائم
يعني اذا كان هذا الامر حقيقي وهذا ما نص
عليه الاتفاق لماذا
تتم معارضته من قبالكم وهذا مطلبكم في
الاساس
اا التحيه للشعب السوداني العظيم
والرحمه والمغفره لشهر الشهداء الثورات
السودانيه همم وكذلك الشفاء العاجل لجرحى
همم
الذين تعرضوا
للاعتداءات في مظاهرات اليوم من لجام
مقاومه وغيره من الشعب السوداني ومن
السوار الذين ساروا في شوارع الخرطوم
المختلفه همم الاتفاق ال همم الثنائي همم
ونحمل الذين وقعوا الاتفاق همم ما حدث ل
همم الشعب السوداني اليوم من انتهاكات ومن
جرحها وغيره همم
القمعيه بما فيها ال- همم المكونه همم
العسكري همم نحن ندين هذه التصرفات
في في همم حتى يعني حتى لا نخسر الوقت
لندخل في هذه النقطه بالتحديد سبب الرفع
لهذا الاتصال
نعم نحن لدينا تجارب كبيره مع الاتفاقيات
الثنائيه
المختلفه بما فيها اتفاق همم 21 همم فلذلك
بعد توقيت اتفاق السلام تنادينا بحوار
شامل وهمم
حكومه ذات قائده عريضه همم يشارك في كل
ثوار كل الذين شاركوا في ثوره ديسمبر
وحركات الكفاح المسلح همم ولكن لم نتوفق
في ذلك بسبب الصراعات اللي موجوده في ال-
الحريه والتغيير فنحن بنعلم تماما بان
حكومه حمده كانت ايضا حكومه مدنيه همم
كامله وهمم وهذا الاتفاق هي اتفاق شراكه
بين جزء او بعض همم
المجلس المركزي
والمكونه العسكري بدليل ان برهان قال بان
العسكر للسكنات
همم بعد همم حكومه منتقبه وكذلك حتى
الحكومه المدنيه في مجلس السياده همم
حينما سئل برهان اليوم همم تحدث عن ان ليس
لها الحق في تعيين همم القائد الاعلى
للقوات المسلحه وكل الاجهزه الامنيه
الاخرى تعيينها بيتم همم وفقا لترتيبات في
داخل المنظومات نفسها ووفقه قوانين تلك
الاجهزه واسلاح الاجهزه نفسها هي مسئوليه
همم القوات المسلحه حسب الاتفاق همم ايضا
اتفاق همم هنالك قوه كبيره جدا لم يكن جزء
من الاتفاق كانت اتفاقك همم معروفه في
مؤسسه للحريه والتغيير بما فيها الحريه
والتغيير الكتله الديمقراطيه للموضوع
الاساسي
وه امر همم يعني همم من المفيد سؤال
السيده سلمى همم بشانه سيده سلمى التجارب
السابقه ايضا كما يقول ضيفنا كانت همم
تتحدث بنفس العناوين من دون ان يتغير اي
شيء او ينفذ منها اي شيء فضلا عن انه حتى
هذه المره هناك جزء اساسي ايضا من قوى
الحريه والتغيير والقوه المدنيه غير
مواثقه على هذا الاتفاق ما ردوا كيف
باختصار ارجوك
هو طبعا من الواضح جدا انه ضايفه كالكريم
لم يطلع على هذا الاتفاق ولا يعرف بنوده
كما انه لم يطلع على اتفاق الواحد
والعشرين منه نوفمبر ولا يعلم بنوده
ويتحدث هكذا كما تتحدث السوشيال ميديا
وكما تكتب السوشيال ميديا اولا هذا
الاتفاق ليست شراكه جديده مع المكونه
العسكري او الجانب العسكري هذا الاتفاق
اضطر بصوره واضحه جدا لخروج مكونه من
العسكري من الحياه السياسيه ومن همم
الحكومه وكذلك حكومه الدكتور حمدوك لم تكن
حكومه مدنيه بالكامل هذا ما ادلى به ضيفك
الكريم حكومه الدكتور عبد الله حمدو كانت
نتائج لشراكه الطرط لها واسست لها الوثيقه
الدستوريه 2019 وهذا ما قام البرهان
بالانقلاب عليه في الخامس والعشرين من
اكتوبر بمعاونه ضيفك الكريم ومؤسس الضيف
كا الكريم وبمعاونه الكتله الديمقراطيه
التي يدعي اليوم انها هي كانت مؤسس للحريه
والتغيير وانا اريده ان يذكر من هي
الاحزاب السياسيه التي كانت مؤسسه للحريه
ده غير وموجود اليوم في الكتله
الديمقراطيه اعتقد انه لم يجد حزب مؤسس
للحريه والتغيير موجود في الكتله
الديمقراطيه التي دعمت انقلاب للدكتور
انقلاب الجنرال البرهان في الخامس
والعشرين من اكتوبر هذه كتله انقلابيه وهم
وكلاء للانقلابيين واليوم البرهان كما
انقلب على الحريه والتغيير في ال 25 من
اكتوبر اليوم همم بتوقيعه على الاتفاق
السياسي او الاتفاق الايطالي مع المكونات
المدنيه
كما قال همم البرهان الاتفاق يعني
بالامكان مناقشه بعض البنود همم في
باعتبار انه غير نهائي وهمم القوه الحريه
والتغيير وقوه اخرى ايضا
مدعوه للانضمام اليه هل يمكن ان تدخل هذه
القوه الى هذا الاتفاق والنقاش بما انه هو
اتفا بطاري نقاش بعض التفاصيل من داخله
باختصار ارجوك
همم لا يوجد قوى يدخل في اتفاق لا يؤسس
لحكومه ديمقراطيه ولا يؤسس لسلامه يهدد
بامني واستقرار البلد والتفكك هذا البلد
الحشي اتفاق ضد السلام كما هو موجود فيها
لا يوجد هو يعرف يدرك المهددات التي تواجه
الدوله السودانيه همم يكون جزء من هذه
العمليه المنحره همم الديفك الكريم همم
تقول وتردد هي شريكه اساسيه بتوقيع اليوم
هي خرجت من الثوره همم السودانيه هي لا
ليس لها الحق ان تتحدث عن الثوره وانسوار
نحن ليس لدينا اي اتفاق ونكرر ذلك واليوم
بالتوقيعكم هذا اثبت ما كنا نقوله باننا
لسنا شركاء مع المكونه العسكري ولم نكون
نحن همم
سلام جوبا وسنظل اتفاق سلام همم جوبا
سنزال لا نقف معكم ولا مع المكونات
سابقه او قادمه نظم التحول الديمقراطي نحن
مع السلامه غدا نحن فكره
الانتهاء الوقت سيد نور الدين طه من
الخرطوم القيادي في قوه الحريه والتغيير
الكتله الديمقراطيه وشكرا لك سلمان نور
عضو قوه الحريه والتغيير مجموعه المجلس
المركزي
شهيد القصر الرئاسي في الخرطوم ويامل
اطرافه ان يكون بدايه الحل للانسداد
السياسي الذي يمر به السودان جميل الاتفاق
اكثر من مستوى فنصت بنده على ابعاد الجيش
عن اي عمل سياسي وعلى دمج قوات الدعم
السريع في القوات المسلحه ومنعه تشكيل اي
ميليشيا عسكريه او ما يشبهها سيدخل سوداني
بموجب الاتفاق فتره الانتقاليه مدتها عمان
تبدا من تعيين رئيس الوزراء يختاره ما سمي
قوه الثوره وعارفه تكون السلطه الانتقاليه
مكونه من مجلس تشريعيه الانتقالي ومستوى
انسياديين انتقالي ومجلس الوزراء انتقاليا
ومجالس عدليه مستقله
خلال الفتره الانتقاليه ستبحث صياغه
الدستور للبلاد ثم تنظم عمليه انتخابيه
شامله في نهايه تلك الفتره بنود الاخرى
توفي على تاجيل مناقشتها وهي العداله
الانتقاليه والاصلاح الامني والعسكري
واتفاق جوبا للسلام وتفكيك نظام الرئيس
المعزول عمر البشير
لابد من الاشاره هنا للاطراف الموقعه على
اتفاق الاطار مع المجلس السيادي وابرز
واحسب الامه القومي والمؤتمر السوداني
والتجمع الاتحاد والمؤتمر الشعبي وانصار
السنه والاتحاد الحسن المرغني والتحالف
الوطني السوداني والجبهه الثوريه وحزب
البعث القومي وتجمع المهنيين باء وحزب
البعث العربي الاشتراكي اما ابرز
المقاطعين للالات فهم والكتله الديمقراطيه
والاتحاد الاصل ورئيس وتنسيقيات شرق
السودان ونداء اهل السودان والتيار
الاسلامي العريض والحزب الشيوعي والجان
المقاومه في الخرطوم وقوه الحراك الوطني
وحزب الامه بقياده مبارك الفاضل
ولهؤلاء المقاطعين اسباب منها رفض التفاوض
والشراكه مع الجيش كما وصف بعض الرافدين
الاتفاق بانه ثنائي واقصائي وادى الى
انشقاقات داخليه
[موسيقى]
جهه تطلق على نفسها اسم لجان مقاومه
الخرطوم وقبل نحو عام شهيد القصر الرئاسي
وتوقعات اتفاق سياسي لاستكمال المسار
الديمقراطي بين رئيس الوزراء المعزول من
الجيش انا ذاك عبد الله حمدوك وقائد الجيش
عبد الفتاح البرهان وفي عام 2019 كانت قوه
الحريه والتغيير قد وقعت مع المجلس
العسكري وثيقه اتفاق سياسي حدد وقتها
كيفيه اداره البلاد عبر مجلس انسيادي
[موسيقى]
في تونس كده المتحدث باسم حركه النهضه
عماد الخميري ان ما سماها سلطه الانقلاب
فشلت في اداره جميع
صعبه
السياسيه للانتخابات المرتقبه خلال الشهر
الجاري ستعمق الازمه الدستوريه في البلاد
وان هذه الانتخابات ستتحدث المزيد من
الانقسام على حد تعبيره
المشترك بتاع غياب الاحزاب ومقاطعت اغلب
مكونات الطائف السياسي والحزبي لهذه
الانتخابات يبين انه اليوم انه الانتخابات
هديه لن تكون عنوان للحل بل ستكون تكريس
لمزيد الانقسام وستعمق الازمه الدستوريه
ستعمر ازمه الشرعيه في البلاد ونعتبر انه
ايضا الاستمرار في نهج الهروب الى الامام
وافتعال القضايا هذا ما عنده ما يوصل
للتعرف اكثر على خريطه المشهد السياسي في
تونس قبيل الانتخابات القادمه نتابعوا هذا
التقرير
اقل من اسبوعين على موعد اجراء الانتخابات
التشريعيه في تونس هي الاولى منذ قرارات
الرئيس قيس سعيد في الخامسه والعشرين من
يوليو 2021 التي قضت باقاله الحكومه وحل
مجلس النواب وينتظر ان تجرى تحت ظل دستور
الجديد ووفق قانون الانتخابي معدل فمن
سيشارك ومن سيقاطعوا هذه المحطه
الانتخابيه التي توصف بانها ستكون مواجهه
بين الاحزاب المواليه للرئيس والمستقلين
في ظل غياب شبه كلي للقوه السياسيه التي
شكلت البرلمان الماضي
المشاركون حتى الان في الانتخابات المزمع
اجرائها في السابعه عشر من الشهر الجاري
هي حركه الشعب ذات التوجه القومي الناصري
حركه تونس الى الامام المنتميه لليسار
التيار الشعبيين ذو التوجه الاشتراكيه
القومي حزب التح في من اجل تونس حراك ال
25 من يوليو
باستثناء حركه الشعب التي كانت تملك 15
مقعدا في برلماني 2019 فان البقيه لم يكن
لها اي تمثيل نيابي
مقاطعون انتخابات الذين يتهمون رئيس قيس
سعيد بانه يسعى لتشكيل المجلس النيابي
كوري
بصلاحيات ثانويه ودور رقابي مفقود
جبهه الخلاص المكونات من ائتلاف عده احزاب
في مقدمتها حركه النهضه صاحبه الاغلبيه
البرلمانيه في المجلس المنحل باثنين
وخمسين مقعدا حزب قلبي تونس الذي كان له
ثمانيه وثلاثون مقعدا في البرلمان الماضي
ائتلاف الكرامه الذي مثل في برلمان 2019 ب
21 نائبا حركه الامل حراك تونس الاراده
تنسيقيه الاحزاب اجتماعيه والديمقراطيه
التي تضم التيار الديمقراطي الذي كان له
في البرلمان الماضي 22 مقعدا حزب العمال
الحزب الجمهوري حزب القطب الديمقراطي
الحزب الدستوري الحر الذي يعد اكبر خصوم
حركه النهضه وكان له في برلمان 2019
17 مقعدا حزب افاق تونس حركه مشروع تونس
التي مثلت في البرلمان الماضي باربعه
مقاعد المسار الديمقراطي الاجتماعي واخيرا
الحزب الاشتراك
وسبق للاتحاد التونسي للشغل وهو اكبر كيان
النقابيا وعمالين في البلاد ان اعلن رفضه
للمسار السياسي الحالي بسبب التفرد بالحكم
والغموض وكلمات امينه العام نور الدين
الطبوبي الطبوبي اعتبر ان تونس مقبله على
الانتخابات لا لون ولا طعم لها وان
الدستور لا يحظ موافقتي اغلبيه التونسيين
معنا من تونس قيصر صياح المحامي والباحث
القانوني كذلك معنا من تونس عبد اللطيف
المكي الوزير السابق والقيادي في جبهه
الخلاص الوطنيه ادى معك سيد قيصر السياح
كيف يمكن الانتخابات
كل القوى السياسيه الرئيسيه في البلاد ان
تنتج برلمان ممثلا للشعب التونسي
همم
انتخابات يعني
يوم 19 ديسمبر
ستتشكلوا فيها ومنها همم مجموعه من
النظريه الجديده يعني السياسه في تاريخ
تونس وستعطي همم
الحياه السياسيه
بيكافه السياسيه الموجوده على الاقل
سياسي لانه همم
المشهد السياسي كان عانى منذ ثوره عديده
الاهتزازات
التي ادت الى همم
سياسي يعني مغترب كاد ان يؤدي الى زلزال
سياسي واقتصادي وانهيار لم يشهد التاريخ
وكاله
تحذير حدود سياسي تقريبا انتجت 120 سياسه
بالانتخابات همم قبل الاخيره وال120 حزب
سياسي لم يكون ولم يخلف ومشهدا سياسيا
يعني يعطي لتونس هذا التنوع واجب
اليها هذا بدا كانت الاصوات بطبيعه الحال
والشيختها موزه والبعض من الاحزاب وصلت
بين السفر
لم يلبسوا من ذلك المشهد الا حزبين او
ثلاثه هم بينهم هذا وحزب ميدا تونس
فبالتالي المشهد السياسي
الفتره لم يكن كفيا لاعطاء المشهد السياسي
حقه كما يجب وكان المشهد السياسي حتى
الاحزاب مضطربه جدا ولم ياتي بحلول كفيله
لانقاذ البلاد
نعم سيد قيصر اتضحت الفكره سيد عبد اللطيف
المكي همم اذا مشهد سياسي همم تكون تونس
قديمه عليه نتيجه انتخابات السابع عشر من
ديسمبر والانتخابات
السابقه لم تنتج مشهدا سياسيا همم
يعني يفرض حلولا على ساحه السياسيه هذا ما
همم يطمح اليه في الانتخابات القادمه ما
ردواك
اهلا وسهلا بكم
استاذ سياح
ما واكده وستثبته الايام ان المشهد
السياسي الذي صنعوا قيس سعيد بن قلابه
سيكون ارده واعجز واكثر تشتيت لكلمه تونسي
واكثر زرعا للاحقاد وللحزازيات نحن لا
ننكر انه قبل انقلاب قيس سعيد كانت هنالك
مشاكل سياسيه كان يجب معالجتها بالحكمه
ودعوني السيد قيس سعيد الى تبني مشروع
الحوار الذي اخترعه عليه اتحاد الشغل من
اجل ان تجاوز تلك المشاكل ايمانا منا لان
الديمقراطيه تشمل الجميع ولكنها تتحرك
ببطء وان الرئيس دوره الاساسي هو التجميع
كلمه التونسي ولكنه كان يوظف تلك المشاكل
ورفض تبني هذا الحوار ووظفها لتبريره
انقلابه وبالتالي عالج الخطا بالخطيئه
واليوم قيس سعيد في سبر الاراء هو في
انحدار رهيب المشاكل تتراكم على رؤوس
التونسيين فقدان
المواد الاساسيه الضروريه مثل الحليب
والزيت الى غير ذلك الان التونسيون
المهددون بتوقف توزيع الدواء واعلن
كلاياكل المكلفه بتوزيع الدواء انها امام
سياسه الحكومه لا تستطيع
البلاد القديم على الانتخابات سيد عبد
اللطيف البلاد قادمه على انتخابات اذا اذا
كان الامر كذلك يفترض ان يظهر ذلك في
صناديق الاقتراع اليس كذلك
لا يمكننا ان نشرعن الانقلاب نحن بذلنا
حياتنا مئات والاف المناضلين من مختلف
المشارب السياسيه يا ساريه واسلاميه
وليبراليه ومستقلون بذلنا اعمارنا في
السجون وفي الكفاح من اجل الديمقراطيه لا
يمكن اليوم ان نسجل في تاريخنا اننا نشرعا
انقلاب عبر المشاركه في هذه المهزله
الانتخابيه لا يمكننا اليوم ان الغشاء
شعبنا ولا نقول له انقلاب قيس سعيد بما في
ذلك
انتخابات
المزعومه انها ستاتي بالحل التونسي
التونسيون بانفسهم يعانون اليوم كل يوم
المشاكل والمساعده ولم يعد مقتنعين
ببرنامج قيد سعيد وقي سعيد متخوف جدا من
تدني نسبه المشاركه ولذلك نصبر على مقاومه
الانقلاب افضل من ان نسوق الانتخابات لم
تفضي الا اذا
قيصر
ان تكون كل القوه السياسيه واخرها الاتحاد
التونسي للشغل رافض لهذه الانتخابات وما
سنتج عن عن هذه الانتخابات الا يعني ذلك
شيئا للرئيس قيس سعيد
هو ده قبل كل شيء وجهه نظر سيدنا
ملايين تقريبا تقريبا
الذي انتخب قيس السعيد نسبه التصويت
السعيد كمال
النقيس صعيدي هناك مشاكل موجوده في
المشاكل لكن هذه المشاكل احسن كما قال في
في وقت ما الرئيس الامريكي جورج بوش الاول
قال ليس كان احسن من المكان نحن الان في
وضعيه عن عشناها منذ تقريبا عشر سنوات
تخبطت فيها الاحزاب والاتحاد العام نفسه
لم يجد البديل واضطر العالم الى اعطاء
تونس جائزه نوبل
الفتره التي كانت تقودها الاحزاب السياسيه
التي
احزاننا القادمه
الى الحد الذي حكمت فيه الدوله بثلاثه
رؤوس التنفيذ الحكومه والرئيس الدوله
والتشريعيه والتي كانت لديها 120 مشروع
قانون وركز دون البيتي فيه الان ونحن على
على الاقل على مستوى تغيير مسح السياسي
نقمح الى ما هو افضل
عذرا عذرا للمقاطعه انتهى الوقت شكرا
جزيلا لك من تونس المحامي والباحث
القانوني وشكرا لعبد اللطيف المكي ايضا
القيادي في جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه كان معنا
من تونس
قال المعهد الوطني للاحصاء في تونس ان
معدل التضخم السنوي في البلاد ارتفع الى
مستوى قياسيه خلال شهر نوفمبر تشرين
الثاني المنصرم واكد المعهد ان النسبه
التضخم قربت 10% بزياده اكثر من نصف نقره
مئويه عما كانت عليه في اكتوبر الماضي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت سلطات الاوكرانيه تعرض مناطق كياذ
واخرسون وزابولوجيا وميكو لايف لقصف روسيا
بالصواريخ من البحر الاسود وبحر قزوين
واقل الرئيس الاوكراني ان قوه الدفاع
الجوي اسقطت معظم صواريخ الروسيه التي
استهدفت العديد من المقاطعات الاوكرانيه
واوضح ان الكهرباء ستعود تدريجيا الى
المناطق التي قطعت عنها بسبب القصف الروسي
رؤيه رؤيه
على جهوده اسقط الدفاعاتنا الجويه معظم
الصواريخ اليوم والكهرباء وتعوده تدريجيا
لا يمكن ان تكسر ارادتنا
قالت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
على مطرين عسكريين في وسط وجنوب البلاد
باستخدام سيارات
عسكريين روس قتلوا واصيب 40
موجوده حول النظام كيف تعطيل الطائرات
الروسيه بعيده المداعب برشلونه طائرات
بدون طيار سوفتيه الصنع ضربات على مطار
روسيين لكن دفاعاتنا الجويه
طفيفه كما قتل ثلاثه عسكريين روس كانوا في
المطار وجرح اربعه اخرون عطلنا نظام نقل
احتياطيات القوات الاوكرانيه والاسلحه
الاجنبيه والمعدات والذخيره الى مناطق
القتال عبر خطوط السكك الحديد وذلك بقصفنا
مجمعا ومراكز اتصالات ووحدات للطاقه
ووحدات عسكريه
معنى من جنيف العقيده الكسندر فود ترافير
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
مرحبا بك سيد الكسندر ماذا يعني ان ااه
تصبح القواعد الجويه الروسيه في وسطها
جنوب البلاد كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه هدفا لهجمات بمسيرات اوكرانيه
الان نهايه
هجمه بريه بريه كبيره كانت ناجحه من
الجانب الاوكرانيه والان نحن نستانف الحرب
الجويه وهي الحرب التي كانت ربما لا تقاتل
في وقت مبكر وكان هذا المتوقع من القوه
الجويه الروسيه لذلك ما نراه الان هو همم
فصل الاول من الحرب يتم اعادته يعني نحن
الان همم في فصل الشتاء سنكون امام حرب
جويه بين الطرفين بديل عن الحرب البريه
غير الممكنه بفعل عوامل الطقس
نعم هذا صحيح وايضا ان الروس هم يستفيدون
خياراتهم وهم ليس لديهم خيارات اخرى في
الحرب المدرعه بالنسبه للمدرعات والدبابات
قد عانوا من خسائر فادحه وقد كانت هنالك
دائما لديهم نقص في القوات القوات البريه
وهم الان متخلفين من ناحيه الامكانيات
والمدى فيما يتعلق بالمدفعيه بالتالي
بطاقه او الكارت الوحيد والورقه المتوفره
لدى الروس القوه الجويه
[موسيقى]
بامكانهم همم اطلاق صواريخ بعيده المدى
على رغم الحديث الدولي المستمر الغربي
تحديدا عن نفاذ الصواريخ الروسيه لكن
عمليا ما زالوا همم يستهدفون ثيا ومناطق
بعيده عن الحدود وبامكانهم الوصول همم
اليها فضلا عن انهم همم اقوى في المجال
الجوي من اوكرانيا
الملاحه والقوه الجويه التكتيكيه الوهي
همم لا يتم المقارنه بين روسيا
والاوكرانيه وايضا القوه الجويه
للستراتيجيه التي تتفوق فيها روسيا حقا ما
نراه ان القوه الجويه التكتيكيه للقوه
للجانب الروسيه لم تكن ناجحه في هذه
الحمله وكما في الانقراطات السابقه نرى ان
روسيا
تقع همم عليها
قوه وبامكانيه الوصول الى مسافات واسع
باستخدام او سافات عفوا بعيده باستخدام
القوه الصاروخيه شكرا جزيلا لك العقيده لك
رئيس تحرير المجله العسكريه السويسريه
حدثنا من جانب
[موسيقى]
دخلها قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول مجموعه
الساده واستراليا تحديد سعر النفط الروسي
حيز التنفيذ يسعى القرار الذي يحدد ب 60
دولارا سعر برميل الروسي الى تقليل قدره
موسكو على تمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا وقال
لكريم لين ان الاجراء الغربيه لن يؤثر على
مجهود موسكو الحربي في اوكرانيا وحذرا من
الزعزاعه استقرار سوق الطاقه العالميه
يوم عصيب على النفط الروسي ففي الخامس من
ديسمبر 2022 واجه هذا القطاع الاستراتيجي
قرارين مؤلمين متزامين لقد بدا سريان
مفعول قرار الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول مجموعه
السبع الصناعيه الكبرى واستراليا القاضي
باعتماد مبلغ 60 دولارا سعرا اقصى لبرميل
الخام الروسي كما دخل حيز التنفيذ قرار
الاتحاد الاوروبي حذرا نفط الروسي المنقول
بحرا وهو ما سيلغى فعليا وفوريا ثلثي
والدتي دول الاتحاد منه اما تحديد سعر
فيترتب عليه عدم السماح لاي جهه او شركه
بنقل اي نفط روسي يتخطى السعر المحدد كما
تتطلع الدول صاحبه القرار الى تعميم هذا
السقف السعر على معظم زبائن روسي عبر
العالم ومن بينهم الصين والهند
يهدف القراران لا تقليس ايرادات موسكو
الماليه الهائله من مبيعات النفط وبالتالي
الى النيل من قدرته على تمويل حربها على
اوكرانيا مع الحفاظ على تدفق نفطها الى
الاسواق العالميه فسعر 60 دولارا للبرميل
يظل اعلى بكثير من تكلفه الانتاج الحاليه
في روسيا مما يحفزها على الاستمرار في
ضخام وجني عائدات تحتاجها بالحاح في
مواجهه الخطوات الغربيه اعلن المتحدث باسم
الكربلاند بيتر بيسكوف ان بلاده لن تعترف
باي سقف لاسعار الطاقه وانها ستتخذ تدابير
للرد معتبرا النتيجه القرارات لن تؤثر على
المجهود الحربي الروسي في اوكرانيا وستؤدي
فقط الى مزيد من زعزعه استقرار سوق الطاقه
العالمي على حد قوله
لكن التصريحات السياسيه قد لا تتطابق
دائما مع الحقائق الاقتصاديه في روسيا هي
ثاني اكبر مصدر للنفط الخام في العالم واي
عقوبات ستؤثر حتما على هذا القطاع الذي
تزداد الحاجه اليه جر الحرب وحلول فصل
الشتاء
الاسواق ايضا كان ردها سريعا حيث قفزت
اسعار الخام نحو ثلاثه في المئه بعد ان
ابقى دول وبلاس على العمل باتفاق اكتوبر
الماضي الذي ينص على خفض الانتاج بمقدار
مليونير برميل يوميا بدايه من نوفمبر
تشرين الثاني الماضي وحتى نهايه العام
المقبل
مشاهدينا لاحقا في فقره المتابعه نعود
لموضوع تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي
ونتناول مع ضيفنا اليات تنفيذ هذا الاجراء
ومراحل مراجعته ومدى تداعياته على اسواق
الطاقه في العالم
[موسيقى]
اجرى امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد ال
ثاني مباحثات في الدوحه مع رئيس دوله
الامارات العربيه المتحده الشيخ محمد بن
زايد وقال الديوان الاميري القطري ان
المباحثات تركزت على العلاقات بين البلدين
والسبل الكفيله بدعمها وتوطيدها في مختلف
المجالات واضاف انه جرس استعراض تطورات
الاحداث على الساحتين الاقليميه والدوليه
وتبادل وجوهات النظر حيل عدد من القضايا
ذات الاهتمام المشترك
عقد الشيخ تميم بن حمد الثاني امير دوله
قطر والشيخ محمد بن زايد ال نهيان رئيس
دوله الامارات جلسه مباحثات رسميه في
الديوان الاميري بالدوحه وبحسب بيان
الديوان الامير القطري فقد بحث الجانبان
خلال الجلسه تطوير علاقات التعاون المشترك
بين البلدين وسبل دعمها في مختلف المجالات
اضافه الى تعزيز العمل الخليجي المشترك
كما تم استعراض تطورات الاحداث على
الساحتين الاقليميه والدوليه وتبادل وجهات
النظر حياله عدد من القضايا ذات الاهتمام
المشترك من جانبه وخلال تغريده لها اعرب
رئيس الامارات عن تهاني بمناسبه استضافه
قطر لبطوله كاس العالم الجاريه كما اشاد
بنجاح قطر الاستثنائي في تنظيم واحتضان
مثل هذه البطوله العالميه هذا وقد سباق
واجره وافتان من دوله الامارات ودوله قطر
مباحثات رسميه في الدوحه لتوطيد العلاقات
بين الجانبين ومتابعه تنفيذ بيان قمه
العلا الخليجيه وذلك قبل ايام من هذه
الزياره ويعد الاجتماع الثالث لمتابعه ما
جاء في بيان العلا الذي صدر في المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتعد هذه الزياره الاولى
للرئيس الاماراتي الى قطر منذ توليه منصبه
كرئيس للبلاد وتوقيع اتفاق العلا في
السعوديه في يناير من العام الماضي
شيخ محمد بن زايد قطر بنجاح بطوله كاس
العالم لكره القدم واقل شيخ محمد بن زايد
انه بحث العلاقات بين البلدين وسبل
تعذيزها وتطويرها بما يخدمون المصالحه
المشتركه
مرحبا امير دوله قطر الشيخ تميم بن حمد
الثاني بزياره رئيس دوله الامارات الشيخ
محمد بن زايد ال نهيان للدوحه وقال امير
دوله قطر في تغريده على تويتر
بشان القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه وفي
مقدمتها سبل دعم للامن والاستقرار في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
الروسيه اعتبارا من اليوم الاثنين ما الذي
يعني ذلك
فنصليه المعتمده على السماحي فقط بالنفط
المبيع بسعر 60 دولارا او اقل للبرميل
الواحد ستجري مراجعه هذا السقف اعتبارا من
منتصف كانون الثاني يناير ثم كل شهرين مع
امكاني تعديله وفقا لمستجدات الاسعار على
كل دوله عضو في الاتحاد الاوروبي ومجموعه
الساده الكبرى مراقبه تنفيذ الشركات
الموجوده على اراضيها لهذا الاتفاق فاذا
كانت سفينه ترفع علم بلد اخر وتبين انها
تنقل النفط الروسي لسعر يفوق السقف المحدد
سيمنا وعلى الشركات الغربيه توفير تامين
لها وتمويلها مدتها 90 يوما
توفير دول مجموعه السبعه تسعين في المئه
من خدمات التامين للشحنات العالميه بينما
يشكل الاتحاد الاوروبي طرفا رئيسا في
النقل البحري وهو ما يمنح تجمعين القدره
على فرض هذا السقف على غالبيه زبائن روسيا
عبر العالم
يهدف تحديد سقف لاسعار النفط الروسي الذي
اقره الاتحاد الاوروبي ودول مجموعه سبع
الكبرى واستراليا يهدف الى الحد من قدره
موسكو على تمويل الحرب في اوكرانيا لكن
السؤال المطروح ما هو تاثيره هذا الاجراء
يدور سعر برميل النفط الخام من جبال
الاورال حاليا في حدود 65 دولار اي انه
اعلى بقليل من سقف الستينا دولار ومن ثم
يمكن ان يكون تاثيره تحديد سقف للسعر
محدودا على المدى القصير الامر الذي يثير
السياسيه التي نددت بما اعتبرته اجراءا
غير كافا لمعاقبتي موسكو
وبوسع الدول التي لم تنضم رسميا الى اليه
تحديد السقف بوسعها شراء نفطر روسي بسعر
يفوق السقف المحدد بالستين دولارا من دون
اللجوء الى خدمات الغربيه مثل التامين
والنقل والوساطه لشراء هذا النفط او نقله
وقد تحاول روسيا تشكيله اسطول خاص بها من
ناقلات النفط تشغله وتوفر له التامين وهو
ما يمكن ان تفعله الصين والهند ايضا وهما
ابرز زبائنها
نشير الى ان روسيا هي ثاني مصدر للنفط
الخام في العالم ومع دخول تحديث سقط لسعر
نفطها حيز التنفيذ ارتفع سعره الخام بنحوه
1.8 في لندن ونيويورك
طبعا هذا الموضوع سنناقشه بتفاصيله مع
ضيفنا
ميلان
الكيبورد الباحث في سياسات الطاقه بمركز
الدراسات السياسيه الاوروبيه معنى من
بروكسل اذا 60 همم دولار تحديد
سقف سعر النفط ما الذي سيؤثره عمليا اذا
كان السعر المتداول اصلا هو يعني بحدود ال
65 دولار
يوتيوب
السقف المتفق عليه هو اقل بقليل من اسعار
السوق لكن دول السبعه والدول الاوروبيه
تحدثت عن هذا الامر لمده ولا شيء لاهم في
ذلك انه تم توصل على اتفاق الى اتفاق الى
مسالتي كبحي عوائد النفط التي تصل الى مصر
وتوافق على هذا الامر وتوصل الى سقف اولي
بامكان هذا السعر ان يتم مراجعته مستقبلا
بالتالي قد يكون
عندما نعرف كيفيه تطبيق هذا الامر
بامكاننا ان ندرس همم سقفا اضافيا او
مختلفا ايضا هذا السقف على النفط الروسي
يتم التوافق عليه بين استراليا ودول
السبعه الكبرى لكن
يعني هو اعتقدوا ان هذا ايضا يؤثر على
النفط الخام وايضا الدول الاوروبيه لن
تقوم باستهلاك اي همم نفط الروسيه يتم
استيراده من قبل البحر هذا كله يؤثر على
عوائد
النفط الروسيه بالتاليه يضع قيودا عليها
حتى ولو كانت تمر عبر طرف ثالث ولكن
روسيا بمساعده الصين والهند من تامين
بدائل بدائل للنقل بدائل التامين خصوصا
انه هناك دول كثيره تحتاج الى همم الروسي
ماكنه زمان
تم تصميمها من اجل استهداف عوائد روسيا
وليس تجهيز النفط الروسي الى دول خارج
الاتحاد الاوروبي صحيح ان دول اخرى بتحتاج
الى الطاقه
ما تحاول هذه الاله القيام به هو التوازن
لكن حرمان روسيا في نفس الوقت من العوائد
وهذا صحيح انه قد يكون هنالك بعض الطرق
لمحاولتي الالتفافي همم حول هذه القرار
لكن ليست كل هذه الخيارات ستكون رخيصه
الثمن كلما زادت صعوبه هذه الاجراءات وست
ستكون ثمنها اعلى
وبالتالي قد يكون هذا الامر له تاثير على
الاقتصاد الروسي في نهايه المطاف على
الاقتصاد العالم مثلا لو قررت روسيا عدم
بيع سعرها عفوا عدم بيع نفطها بهذا همم
السعر
لروسيا بعدمه البيع لكنه الامر ليس بهذه
السهوله لدينا انواع مختلفه من النفط
الخام وبعض انواع النفط تحتاجه ان يتم
همم
اذا ما التزمت الدول الاخرى بنظام العقبه
ايضا بالنسبه لتخفيض الانتاج قد يكون
جذابا هذا الامر جذاب القيام به لكنه يخلق
ضغط على الاسعار ايضا
شكرا جزيلا لك ميلان الكروبوت الباحث في
سياسات الطاقه بمركز دراسات السياسه
الاوروبيه من بروكسل
مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور الان من ساو
باولو وريو دي جانيرو الصور الاحتفالات
مشجعين منتخب البرازيل
بصعود فريق السامبا الى دور ربع النهائي
في مونديال قطر 2022 بعد الفوز على كوريا
الجنوبيه باربعه اهداف مقابل هدف واحد
[موسيقى]
4000 سجلها فريق السامبا في الشوط الاول
من المباراه
[موسيقى]
منتصف الليل راس الساعه وهذا موعدنا مع
موجز لاهم الانباء قبل الانتقال الى
الجوله الرياضيه يوميات المونديال
اعلن رئيس مجلس السياده السوداني عبد
الفتاح البرهان التوقيع مع اطراف المدنيه
على اتفاق سياسيا لمرحله الانتقاليه مدتها
24 شهرا وينص الاتفاق على ان المرحله
الانتقاليه تبدا من تاريخ تعيين رئيس
الوزراء وتنتهي باجراء انتخابات عام
وتعهد البرهان بمعالجه اخطاء النظام
السابق بشان المؤسسه العسكريه وفي مقابلات
مع الجزيره اضاف البرهان ان الاتفاق
الايطاليه
غير الموقعه عليه وانه لا اقصاء لاحد
بدوره وصف نائب رئيس مجلس السياده
على السلطه في الخامس والعشرين من اكتوبر
بالخطا السياسيه التي فتح الباب على
الانقسامات
اكد المتحدث باسمي حركه النهضه ان
الانتخابات التشريعيه المرتقبه الشهر
الجاري لن تكون حلا بل ستكرس مزيدا من
الانقسام محذرا من تداعياتي مقاطعتها
قصفت القوه الروسيه العاصمه الاوكرانيات
بوابل من الصواريخ ما تسبب في انقطاع
التيار الكهربائي على نطاق واسع واقل
الرئيس الاوكراني ان الدفاعات الجويه
اسقطت معظم الصور
ادور اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان
دفاعتها الجويه تصدت لهجوم اوكرانيا
بمسيرات صوفيا الصنع على مطرين عسكريين في
وسط وجنوب البلاد واوضح المتحدث ان ثلاثه
عسكريين روس قتلوا واصيب 4 اخرون وتضررت
طائرتان
دخل حيز التنفيذ اليوم قرر دول الاتحاد
الاوروبي حضر واردات النفط الخام الروسي
المنقوله بحرا واقل المتحدث باسم الكرملين
ان الاجراء لن يؤثر على الحرب في اوكرانيا
واحذر من زعزعات استقرار سوق الطاقه
العالميه
في واشنطن مكالمه مناسب للاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه للبيت الابيض جون كيربي ان
الولايات المتحده تريد استقرار سعر النفط
في السوق العالميه واستبعد حدوث تداعيه
بعيده المدى على الاسعار العالميه
شكرا للمتابعه والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]